people ask me all the time why are you  trying to apply research to something  that's organic and how can you bottle up  love so my response to them it's  actually the first paragraph of my book  is that yes love is natural and we're  born knowing how to love but dating  isn't in history people would help you  right there was the Matchmaker or maybe  your father all these other people  involved it's actually a really New  Concept that you on your own Define all  of these characteristics of your life  including who you marry and so people  need help second of all there is  academic research on this why is love  something that has to defy logic and  defy science and so I would say this is  something that you care about and you  want to find someone great and not get  divorced why wouldn't you invest in  knowing the information out there it can  only Empower you and you can take the  parts of it that are useful and you can  ignore the other parts  foreign